movistar planet ja meine damen und
herren herzlich willkommen hier heute
mal wieder zu einer weiteren folge
movistar planet mit mir
luca und mit ihnen unter meinem letzten
mobistar planet video meinten ganz ganz
viele leute ich sollte in dieser folge
mal probieren wenn ihr blick alles immer
bescheuert hab ich würde sagen wir gehen
einfach mal in diesen neuen raum rein
kleiderordnung was heißt wenn ich irgend
so ein scheiß kaufen muss nur wenige
minuten später präsentieren das in der
haut für den raum
also ich habe jetzt hier so ein babe t
shirt gekauft haben das heißt wir können
jetzt in den millennium bling raum rein
gehen richtig der siebten nicht so bling
bling aus wollen was ich aber für ihn
auf jeden fall noch sagen wollte war das
ihr gesagt habe dass ich in der heutigen
folge mir eine freundin suchen soll
also ich hab ja julia aber fehler fand
nach alle freundinnen gehen wir einfach
mal hier zu der leoni galaxy queen hey
ich bin neu hier erst mal als freund
hinzufügen luca aber ich würde sagen wir
gehen einfach mal ganz gediegen in die
unterhaltung rein und fragen hallo leoni
wie geht's dir gut und er nicht mehr so
gut nachdem du hier ankommst wo kriegen
wir das elfte freundin mittlerweile
stehen hier aber ist schon eine menge
mädels um dir um die fragt ob ich ein
video drehen
obwohl also die sind echte alle ein
bisschen komisch da vorne m ich geh mal
hier rüber zu meinen hobbys zum beispiel
team hier jetzt einfach die ganze zeit
nur um ganzen justin biebs was ist ein
status aussteigen seriencharakter rat
fest aller jobs den ja so ein hammer
poetischen satz in seinem status hat
würde ich jetzt einfach auf was bedeute
dass man ihm raushauen ein schweinfurt
bis zu 4000 mal pro jahr
hahahahaha sehr interessant xd ich fühle
mich wie sollen lehrer vielleicht habe
ich mich aber mal ein bisschen auf meine
ursprüngliche mission des heutigen
videos hier zurückgewinnen und zwar eine
freundin zu finden ich möchte aber
eigentlich niemanden der mich kennt von
daher verlassen
niebling und beginn ins einkaufszentrum
das würde bat die komme ich heute
einfach mal direkt auf ein prozent frage
jetzt einfach mal so direct trade in die
fresse will jemand meine freundin werden
kann man doch nicht
[Musik]
will jemand meine freundin sein mag mich
viel jemand mich alle verraten ich würde
das einkaufszentrum gegangen weil ich
dachte hey da sind spieler die schon bis
die länderspiele die sind vielleicht
freundlich die hand irgendwie dumm und
beleidigt nicht nur ja komm pack deine
karre aus dicker und er tanzt oder
dienten im kofferraum ich will aber erst
mal wissen mit wem ich sie zu tun habe
von daher schauen wir uns mal den status
an in dem steht bröse gierig knolle
rolle genauso sehe ich das auch so
gierig knolle rolle
was bedeutet ein bescheuerter status
dein status hat keine bedeutung so wie
du in meinem leben ich glaube wir
brauchen neues outfit um so die mädels
platz machen also ich meine 2000 jahren
da wir nun quasi ein komplett neuer
mensch sind mit unserem neuen style
würde ich sagen bewegen wir uns direkt
dorthin wo man sich am besten mädels
aufreißen kann nie klar
also wir sind jetzt jahren club
angekommen von daher habe ich jetzt
einfach mal so eine typische aussage
raus man so sagt wenn man halt in club
geht also ein mega hammer mutter hier wo
partie die erste damals schon
geantwortet auf unseren spruch sie heißt
miss giulietta das ist ihr profil ihr
status ist da wissen wir mit wem wir es
zu tun haben wir schauen mal wenn wir
noch haben und zwar die maria
da gehe ich auch mal auf das profil die
hat als status maria ich bin auch single
alter maria bist du da okay da die maria
anscheinend gerade acht als würde ich
sagen ich einfach wieder die frage raus
will irgendjemand hier meine freundin
sein
mit linda 2009/10 berlin da willst du
mit mir zusammen sein
ja
wir haben sie noch nicht richtig wir
müssen das jetzt erstmal einläuten
melinda afa am dann können wir zusammen
sein will inter hat jetzt wirklich wie
eine freundschaftsanfrage angenommen das
heißt ich kann jetzt hier auf diesen
knopf drücken nach einer beziehung
fragen also mit linda wirklich ich will
ich da überhaupt nicht zu irgendwas
drängen lass dir deine zange den damen
jetzt an alter hab ich kann zu tag zu
gratis testen
die million acres in ihr schaut euch das
an milliliter 2001 kranke scheiße ich
habe eine freundin in einem
computerspiel wahrscheinlich sind deine
eltern zufrieden mit der entscheidung
das heutige movistar planet video jetzt
allerdings beenden meine lieben freunde
wenn euch der heutige teil gefallen hat
dann hat sie unbedingt einen daumen hoch
unter die videodaten schreibt mir jetzt
mal unten in die kommentare
was sich in der nächsten folge nächste
woche machen soll falls sie diese folge
nicht verpassen wollt dann abonniert
main kanal
das ist kostenlos dann verpasste keine
videos mehr und ich sehe mir das voll
viele leute gar keine abonnenten sind
von einem kanal aber trotzdem sich meine
videos anschauen also klicken auf
abonnieren da verpasste keine videos
mehr und jetzt kommt das ausreiche so
froh wir haben die freunde gefunden
[Musik]
nein